[Applaudissements]
merci Madame la Président je voudrais
associer à ma question Valérie Bazin
Malgras 200 millions d'euros ce sont les
pertes de rendement estimés par les
betteraviers à la suite de l'épidémie de
la jaunisse qui a décimé des hectares
entiers de culture en 2020 alors que
cette année noire
semblait appartenir au passé jeudi 19
janvier 2023 la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne en a décidé autrement
alors en effet jugé illégal les
dérogations accordées aux agriculteurs
pour l'usage de néonicotinoïdes en
enrobage de semences cette décision est
un véritable coup de massue pour la
filière betterave sucre quelques
semaines avant les semis de la campagne
2023 2024 les producteurs sont
aujourd'hui confrontés à une réalité
agronomique qui est à contre-courant des
décisions prises par la cgue alors que
cela fait des semaines que l'on entend
le ministre de la transition écologique
se positionner contre les betteraviers
il a fallu s’est arrêté brutal pour que
nous soyons obligés d'agir dans
l'urgence et sortir de cet impasse
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture
vous proposez un plan d'action en
soutien à la filière mais il nous faut
des engagements con et durable le plan
national de recherche et d'innovation
que vous mentionnez ne demande pas
seulement de l'argent mais aussi du
temps et le temps de nos 24000
betteraviers et compter aussi vous
évoquez dans ce plan d'action un
accompagnement financier mais nos
producteurs de pommes de terre
féculaires se souviennent encore de ses
promesses non tenues alors ou
comptez-vous chercher ces fonds quels en
sont les règles avec ou sans plafond
avec ou sans franchise en dehors des
règles des minimis aujourd'hui aucun
pays membres ne peut déroger à
l'interdiction des nni enrobés sur des
graines de betteraves sauf l'Allemagne
deuxième producteur de betterave à sucre
en Europe après la France qui feinte
cette étape arrêtée en utilisant des
insecticides pulvérisés que vous
interdisez en France les mêmes règles
dans l'UE doivent s'appliquer pour tous
monsieur le ministre comptez-vous monter
au créneau pour proposer l'instauration
des mêmes règles du jeu au sein de
l'Union européenne pour préserver notre
souveraineté agricole et permettre aux
agriculteurs français de fournir le
sucre le bioéthanol le gel hydruque
hydroalcoolique dont nous avons besoin
chaque jour merci beaucoup